alors voir donc l'impact concret dans
l'économie avec véronique pukkila pdg
des manufacturiers et exportateurs du
québec et michel rochette qui est le
président du conseil canadien du
commerce de détail pour le québec
bonsoir
vers une expo d'abord quel est l'impact
du blocage au pont ambassadeur pour les
manufacturiers et les exportateurs
écoutez l'impact est énorme c'est un
point de passage qui est très important
pour les manufacturiers québécois
canadien c'est plus de 4000 camions qui
traversent la frontière à tous les jours
traverse le pont alors bien sûr qu'à
court terme on a un impact sur les
délais des délais importants une
augmentation coup également mais je
voudrais que ce qui nous préoccupe
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est l'effet long
terme parce que ce qui arrive ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'il ya un impact un
impact sur l'économie canadienne mais
aussi un impact sur la réputation du
canada à l'étranger en termes
d'investissements aujourd'hui à
plusieurs manufacturiers américains qui
se disent mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
investit au canada quand c'est aussi
compliqué et que le gouvernement fédéral
n'est pas capable de gérer la situation
parce qu'on voit ces images partout dans
le monde présentement tout le monde
parle de sapia même d'autres types de
convoyeurs dans le monde qui sont qui se
prépare et qui organise tout à fait
qu'en fait il ya des manufacturiers
canadiens dont certaines dans le coma
bills ont entendu fouad toyota camp
fermé des usines ici mais également aux
états unis et c'est pourquoi les lois
les voies économique et politique se
lève aussi aux états unis pour robert
rapatrions manufacturier aux états unis
ça file plus simple il faut se rappeler
que ça fait deux ans qu'on une série
d'incidents comme les grèves au port de
montréal les blocus ferroviaire et ce
sont tous des situations où le
gouvernement fédéral à part des ag à
perdre et à intervenir est-ce que les
détaillants michel rochette commence à
ressentir les effets est ce qu'il ya des
délais de livraison même des ruptures
pas de rupture encore vivement y avait
déjà une forte inquiétude comme un homme
prodi avait déjà une forte pression sur
la chaîne d'approvisionnement bien avant
la crise actuelle une suite énorme qui
tend maintenant sur les taux n'est ni
juste rappeler le pont à lui seul le
pont ambassador ses 25% de l'ensemble de
toutes les denrées alimentaires et des
produits de consommation qui circulent
entre les deux oeuvres qui circulent
entre les deux entre les deux pays or
c'est énorme look pour l'instant ce
qu'on constate c'est des délais
l'approvisionnement constate des
variétés en moins sur les étagères mais
la cour court terme on voit pas encore
les impacts mais on commence
sérieusement à voir les effets à venir
très très court moyen terme quand vous
dites vraiment l'alimentaire
l'agroalimentaire est particulièrement
touché par ce qui se passe mais si
rochette ben oui parce que bien encore
une fois ainsi 25% des denrées
alimentaires notamment le qui sont qui
circulent entre les deux pays qui se
passe dans ce projet donc ces normes du
convoi le blocus qui s'élargit à
d'autres gens de passage énorme il
savait dans le domaine du des denrées
alimentaires non périssables l'enjeu est
encore plus grand parce qu'il ya une
question délais réels à très court terme
donc tout ce qui ne traverse pas les
voix est à risque et puis vous savez il
ya des camions qui présenta ne prennent
pas la route juste par crainte d'être
coincé dans un dé dans un des bouchons
là ça fait beaucoup beaucoup dénommé
tous secteurs tout transport était un
maillon essentiel à nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement et surtout loupé le
train lyon c'est l'homme donc
alimentaire agroalimentaire 25 pour ça
je faisais un calcul aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est à peu près 20% du
secteur de l'automobile qui passe à tous
les jours sur le pont ambassadeur ses 50
millions sur 320 millions d'échangés
commerciaux quelques uns des autres
secteurs véronique proulx sont affectées
directement par ce qui se passe
présentement
écouter une multitude d'entreprises qui
utilisent cette voie passage alors j'ai
envie de vous dire ça peut être des gens
dans le secteur récréatif un jeu peut on
peut penser aux papilles papeterie les
gens dans l'acier il ya vraiment une
multitude de secteurs d'activités qui
sont affectés mais je vous dirais que ce
qui arrive c'est que ces camions les
dirige vers d'autres postes frontaliers
notamment à détroit à la colle alors ça
met la pression à la salle ajoute des
repas aux autres postes frontaliers dont
éventuellement c'est l'ensemble des
mêmes s'activer qui vont être affectés
par des délais additionnels encore une
fois est-ce que des fournisseurs
d'automobiles de d'auto parce que
l'ontario honda toyota ford gm states is
beaucoup d' usine où il ya des arrêts de
production présentement on a fabriqué
produits au-delà d'un million de
véhicules en 2021 en ontario
généralement ça va jusqu'à 2 millions de
véhicules donc on comprend que c'est des
milliers de véhicules en ce moment qui
ne sont pas assembler parce que des
arrêts de production est-ce que des
fournisseurs qui sont touchés
jusqu'au québec pourrait-on dire
véronique que pau oui absolument à ce
que plusieurs c'est ce que l'instant
nabil un très forte présence en ontario
monde à des sous traitants au québec des
pme pour qui ces entreprises le sont les
principaux clients alors qu'en ligne de
production s'arrête pas nécessairement
les fournisseurs sont pas en mesure
d'expédier eux non plus donc on a des
sous traitants qui sont affectés ici
mais je réitère sa soient pas les seuls
j'ai des gens vraiment dans différents
secteurs d'activité qui nous interpelle
qui nous disiez des délais de 8h heure
11 heures à la frontière on va payer des
frais additionnels donc s'élancer
donc on fait quoi
michel rochette c'est quoi la solution
qu'est ce qu'on attend du gouvernement
fédéral à l'origine ce qu'elle est une
demande au gouvernement fédéral c'était
d'attendre avant d'imposer la limitation
de nahla halle laquelle elle la
fermeture des frontières aux jeunes au
rex et pourquoi parce qu'au début la
décision était prise au moment où un
micro n'était pas encore dans aucun
paysage on parle encore de fin de
pandémie est arrivé évidemment cette
crise leur descente janvier ils l'ont
appliqué comme si on n'avait pas vu un
micro alors s'ajouter une pression
immense on l'a maintenant qu'on écrit
avec le problème ce qu'il faut au moins
c'est d'envoyer ainsi un transport
évidemment on souhaite évidemment devons
négocier on souhaite pas de problème
mais en même temps il faut que le
gouvernement envoie un signal très fort
avec ça ne peut plus durer et qui
l'envoyaient ultimatum mais le message
doit être ou d'autres est sans équivoque
ouais est ce que vous vous demandez donc
la fin de l'obligation vaccinale pour
les camionneurs à la frontière mais pour
l'instant l'urgence maintenant c'est de
débloquer de votre passage ont doublé de
débloquer les fonds ouais pour ce qui
donne au delà de la question de
vaccination certain que ça ai dit 'tu
dessus évidemment ça porte à porte
vraiment aidé il faut s'assurer au moins
de débloquer les pompiers pas quel pont
ambassador et le dos qui ont ajouté vous
savez donc forcément voyez ici un très
fort pour quel coût pour qu'on puisse
débloquer les pactes et et les peaux
juste sur les étagères et les galères
soli prix sur les prix à la consommation
sur les prix des produits donc que les
gens vont se produire seront ceux pour
se procurer des actions ims vous madame
vous vous étiez contre l'obligation
vaccinale des camionneurs à la frontière
en fait nous ont demandé de reporter de
quelques mois pour laisser la chance
d'augmenter le taux de vaccination des
camionneurs mais là je voudrais
aujourd'hui à vue comme sur hf l'urgence
c'est vraiment de mettre un terme à ce
blocus
on a rencontré hier le ministre des
transports canadien le ministre en
quatre heures et on lui a demandé
clairement gouvernement fédéral 2
exercer un leadership on comprend le
club house un pont privé que de faire un
post company qui sont gérées
différemment soit juste une question
comme suggestion de l'économie
canadienne c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement fédéral et on leur demande
d'exercer un leadership fort 1 pour
mettre terme à ce bleu que ça mais aussi
prévoir la suite pour éviter qu'il
yad'autres situation qui dégénère on le
voyait sur la carte qui est du manitoba
qui commence sa survie et tous les post
ben ali soit privé s'est passé
exactement chaque jour là il commence à
s'additionner comme ça ce type de
manifestation ça pourrait s'étendre et
devenir un mouvement très difficile à
contrôler et déjà que c'est difficile à
contrôler en ce moment véronique proulx
michel rochette merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit